oui bonjour madame la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale bonjour monsieur
le Président du Sénat tout d'abord merci
d'accorder cette interview exclusive aux
chaînne parlementaire dans quelques
instants vous allez rejoindre le cortège
de cette grande marche civique que vous
avez appelé de vos vœux madame bronpivé
vous avez sonné la mobilisation générale
pour quelle raison parce que avec le
président du Sénat nous nous sommes dit
que face à la situation que notre pays
connaît avec cette montée des tensions
cette montée des actes antisémites cette
montée de la haine et des fractures nous
ne pouvions pas ne pas agir et que les
fonctions que nous exercions nous
enjoignaiit de faire quelque chose et de
faire un acte fort et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons décidé ensemble
de faire un grand appel à une marche
civique c'est très important pour nous
que cette marche rassemble au maximum
nos concitoyens oui c'est une démarche
inédite Gérard Larcher cet appel
conjoint de la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale tes vous-même président du
Sénat pour vous le moment l'imposait il
le fallait il faut un sursaut
républicain c'est ce que nous nous
sommes dit lundi tous deux dans le cadre
de rencontrre habituelle que nous avons
et nous avions un ordre du jour mais le
vrai ordre du jour c'était la République
et notre ordre du jour aujourd'hui ce
dimanche c'est la République et la lutte
absolue contre l'antisémitisme qui est
le contraire des valeurs de la
République c'est donc un sursaut que
nous avons appelé et nous souhaitons que
ce sursaut ce soit un sursaut
citoyen est-ce que vous avez regretté
certaines polémiques mais il y en a eu
notamment sur la présence du
rassemblement national dans cette
manifestation est-ce que vous comprenez
ceux qui se sont interrogés ou ceux qui
ont refusé de venir à cause d'une telle
présence madame yelbron pivé vous savez
notre appel c'est un appel pour ce n'est
pas un appel contre et donc nous nous
appelons à marcher pour la République
pour les valeurs qui nous réussissent et
contre l'antisémitisme et donc nous
n'avons invité que les concitoyens nous
n'avons interdit évidemment personne de
manifester mais nous n'avons pas fait un
appel au partis politiques nous aurions
pu le faire comp tenu des
responsabilités qui sont les nôtres ça
n'a pas été notre choix nous avons
décidé de nous adresser directement au
peuple et pour nous les polémiques ne
sont pas à la hauteur ni à la hauteur
des enjeux qui sont comme vient de le
rappeler le président Larcher c'est l'
je c'est la République et donc les
polémiques ne doivent pas salir
l'initiative inédite que nous avons
porté et l'enjeu qui est un enjeu qui
nous dépasse tous mais Gérard l'arché
l'Union nationale elle est impossible
aujourd'hui en France ben nous allons le
voir avec les citoyens l'Union c'est
peut-être les citoyens qui vont la faire
et j'ose espérer que ce sont les
citoyens je pense à ce qui va se passer
à Paris je pense à ce qui se passe
actuellement devant les préfectures à
l'appel des maires il y a cette réaction
de cette trame aussi des 500000 élus
locaux qui disent ça peut pas être comme
ça dans la République chaque citoyen
doit être respecté pour ce qu'il est
quel que soit son origine sa race ou sa
croyance et c'est ça la République et au
fond nous sommes vraiment les héritiers
d'Aristide brillant y compris sur
l'aspect religieux la loi doit protéger
la foi tant que la foi n'entend pas
dicter la loi et nous pensons que c'est
la valeur de la République effectivement
extrêmement important de voir que notre
appel a été démultiplié sur tous les
territoires et moi j'ai eu beaucoup de
bonheur et j'ai du bonheur à voir ces
images des foules réunies à Nice à
Strasbourg à Valence parce qu'on voit
que c'est toute une nation qui répond à
notre appel et ça peut-être que c'est la
première bonne nouvelle de la journée
qu'il y en aura d'autres aujourd'hui je
vais vous parler d'un absent Emmanuel
Macron le chef de l'État ne sera pas
présent dans cette marche Gérard Larcher
est-ce que vous le regrettez écoutez
c'est sa décision
elle lui appartient j'ai compris qu'il
soutenait notre démarche et moi ce qui
compte aujourd'hui c'est vraiment ces
françaises et ces Français qui ont
besoin de se retrouver nous avons besoin
de nous retrouver sur des causes
essentielles et la République
l'antisémitisme ce sont deux causes
majeures et essentielles qui nous
rassemblent même question à Madame roun
pivé cette absence du chef de l'État
vous comprenez ce choix alors le chef de
l'État n'est pas absent il a écrit hier
une une lettre au français pour
justement expliquer à quel point il
tenait aux valeurs de la République il
tenait à ce que cette marche soit une
réussite et il entendait cet appel donc
il en est parfaitement solidaire il le
salue il est avec nous grâce à cette
lettre en pensée et en acte comme il l'a
dit chacun maintenant est à sa place et
ce qui est important c'est que nous nous
sommes à la nôtre à la tête de cette
manifestation madame la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale monsieur monsieur
le Président du Sénat merci infiniment
de nous avoir
accordéole que deux institutions avec
nos sensibilités différentes nous soit
là nous soyons aujourd'hui rassemblés
réunis c'est parce que pour nous la
République ça passe au-dessus de tout
c'est exactement mais nous avons c'est
ça a été noté dans la presse nous avons
des parcours politiques différents nous
avons nous appartenons à des familles
politiques différentes mais nous avons
effectivement cette république en
partage et je crois que c'est ça que nos
concitoyens attendent aujourd'hui des
hommes des femmes politiques de ce pays
que nous sachions nous dépasser que nous
sachions dépasser ce qui peut être
constitué des clivages pour nous
rassembler autour de l'essentiel et
c'est ce que nous faisons aujourd'hui et
bien merci infiniment d'avoir partagé
cette interview sur les chaînes
parlementaires merci